last time you said something about
before you were gonna do heels
but you didn't know if the heels was
gonna happen and the pandemic and all
this all these things
the things that were happening right now
you're doing heels you're in the show
an idea came to you that maybe you know
i don't know i'd consider
uh i consider it another season arrow
maybe i don't know it was just kind of
the back of your mind
right you said that yeah i did and it
was i
i phoned uh
i phoned greg berlanti about it i mean
it's not a
it from my perspective it wasn't a
far-fetched thing
this was this was
in uh um
[Music]
early july um
there was a plan to go back to heels
in late august but this was also during
the
the summer surge that was happening in
the states where they hit
where they hit daily highs like only to
be eclipsed by the daily highs that
that we're about to hit now uh i just
got into
i just got into canada i was
quarantining
it it's you know i'm back in british
columbia it feels so familiar after
eight years of shooting arrow
and i'm also you know looking around at
the fact
that you know
canada has seen a a bit of a
you know a bit of a bump up in in cases
which i think was you know is to be
expected expected but i mean
the numbers relatively speaking are
still so incredibly low
and were even lower at the time i mean
in british columbia
you're looking at you're looking at like
less than 100 cases a day and
and almost all of them believe it or not
we're confined to
retirement facilities and uh prisons
almost all of them and i'm thinking to
myself
you know if everything goes to [ __ ]
um why don't we just do another season
of arrow
because i want to work yeah cause i
called greg up and i said just that i
said look
i i hope this doesn't happen but if
everything goes to [ __ ] and you guys
can't get actors up here
because of you know issues about
mostly american actors crossing into
canada
um and if things can't be if things
can't be figured out
um here's the deal man i'm here
and if i have to stay here i want to
work
if i'm going to work let's
just figure out a way to bring all of
you back from the dead what if berlanti
says like
are you serious yeah he goes are you
serious i go yeah
of course i'm [ __ ] serious again i
hope it doesn't happen
but i mean can we at least put it
like on the radar and he goes
yeah of course you know you know fans
are right now thinking
you know big arrow fans who hopefully
you'll watch heels because
it sounds like it's going to be a badass
show you got a great director great
writer you got [ __ ] steven it's
wrestling it's going to be [ __ ]
powerhouse fun i can tell you that i'll
be watching that [ __ ] but um
hearing you say that they're thinking
well let's say this heel show goes for
five seasons
maybe they do a special season of era
five years from now i they're gonna have
their hopes
but but hey you never know you don't
know we don't know
uh what happens tomorrow so you can't
say no no man
and hey listen and i've always made a
point of never saying i've always made a
point of never saying never
and as a matter of fact when i found out
that um
michael c hall was coming back for a
limited run dexter
as dexter i retweeted the article
and uh despite what despite what our our
president said
a retweet is an endorsement uh
i retweeted that article and i just said
this is why you never say never
and you got it what does he mean by that
it's so cryptic stephen's
got a bit of traction
you